[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشرات الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدموا من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
ولي العهد السعودي يلتقي عدد من القاده
المشاركين في قمه افيك ويبحث معهم الملفات
المشتركه
قال الامير محمد بن سلمان يؤكد على اهميه
التعاون مع كوريا الجنوبيه وتعزيز فرص
التكامل الاستثماري
رئيس الاركان الاسرائيليه يبحث غدا في
واشنطن التحديات الامنيه في المنطقه وفي
مقدمتها تهديدات ايران
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
وزاره التعليم السعوديه تعلن بدء التقديم
على النسخه الثالثه من مسار التميز
للابتعاد
وزاره الصناعه السعوديه تعلن ارتفاع عدد
رخص استكشاف المعادن الى 55 رخصه
حياكم الله على اهم شيء منتدى التعاون
الاقتصادي لاسيا والمحيط الهادئ ايبك
التقى التقى ولي العهد السعوديه الامير
محمد بن سلمان بعدد من قاده الدول حيث
بحثت معهم عددا من الملفات المشتركه
[موسيقى]
وكان ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان وصل الى بانكوك في زياره الرسميه
وكان في مقدمه مستقبلي رئيس الوزراء
التايلندي وتتزامن زياره الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى تايلند مع انعقاد قمه منتدى
التعاون الاقتصادي لاسيا والمحيط الهادي
ابيك في العاصمه التايلنديه اليوم وغدا
وسيلتقي خلالها ولي العهد بالعديد من ابرز
القاده العالميين الذين سيشاركون في
اجتماعات القمه الاقتصاديه
تشهد العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين السعوديه
وتايلاند في الفتره الاخيره حراكا غير
مسبوق في مختلف القطاعات الاستثماريه وذلك
بعد تفعيل الاتفاقيات الموقعه بين البلدين
للوصول بالعلاقات الى مرحله الشراكه
الاقتصاديه الاستراتيجيه والتي ساهمت
بدورها في تسارع وتيره التكامل الاقتصاديه
ما ادى الى رفع حجم التبادل التجاري
بمقدار 29% في عام 2021 مقارنه بعام 2020
ليصل حجم التجاره بين البلدين في العام
2021 لما قيمته سبعه مليارات ومئه مليون
دولار امريكي بفائضا لصالح السعوديه في
سجل الميزان التجاري مجالات التكامل
الاقتصادي اخذت منحنا جديده بعد عوده
العلاقات بين بانكو والرياض حيث تحتل
السعوديه المرتبه الرابعه 10 في قائمه
الشركاء التجاريين لواردات تايلا من
العالم بقيمه تتجا خمسه مليارات و800
مليون دولار امريكي والمرتبه التاسعه
والعشرين في قائمه الشركاء التجاريين
لصادرات تايلاند الى العالم بقيمه مليار
و600 مليون دولار امريكي وفي تطور
المتسارع توجت الرياض بانكوك علاقاتهم
الاقتصاديه بتاسيس مجلس اعمال سعودي
تايلندي لتوسيع نطاق التعاون بينهما في
مختلف المجالات الحيويه بما في ذلك في
قطاعات الطاقه النوويه والطاقه المتجدده
والهيدروجين الاخضر وفي ظل مساعد دولتين
لدعم استقرار اسواق البترول العالميه
وضمان امدادات جميع مصادر الطاقه اتفق
الجانبان على اتخاذ تايلاند مقارا لتخزين
النفط وتصديره الى دول منطقتي شرق اسيا
وجنوبها شرقيه حيث تعد السعوديه شريكا
رئيسيا في مجال الطاقه لتايلاند خصوصا في
امدادات النفط الخام
اما في مجال الزراعه فعمل البلدان على
تسهيل تجاره المحاصيل الاساسيه وخاصه
الارز فضلا عن رغبه السعوديه في تصدير
التمور للاسواق التايلنديه وتعزيز التعاون
مع الجانب التايلندي في مجال الاستزراع
السمكي ومنتجات الدواجن بالاضافه الى
اطلاق مشروعات مباشره في مختلف القطاعات
بين البلدين وتسهيل التنقل والسفر لاغراض
التجاره والسياحه والاستشفاء لمواطن
البلدين واستكشاف مجالات الاستثمار والفرص
المتاحه والمشاريع الكبرى المرتبطه برؤيه
السعوديه 2030
وعلى همشه قمه ابيك عقد اجتماع طارق
لوشنطن وخمس دول حول ازمه صواريخ كوريا
الشماليه ودعت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي
كمارس كوريا الشماليه لوقف استفزازاتها
الصاروخي
الشماليه مره اخرى صاروخا باليسيا عابرا
للقارات سقط على بعد 200 كيلو متر قباله
سواحل اليابان وفقا للجيش الكوري الجنوبي
هو الاحدث في سلسله قياسيه من عمليات
الاطلاق الصاروخيه خلال الاسابيع الاخيره
الولايات المتحده ادانت بشده اطلاق
الصاروخ واعلن انها ستتخذ كافه الاجراءات
اللازمه لضمان ام كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
في حين تعاقد نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كامله
عن طارق على هامشي قمه منتدى التعاون
الاقتصادي لاسيا والمحيط الهادئ في بانكوك
مع قاده الياباني وكوريا الجنوبيه
واستراليا ونيوزلندا وكندا لبحث تداعيات
العمليه كما اعلن مسؤول في البيت الابيض
من قبل كوريا الشماليه انتهاكا لعددان من
قرارات المتحده الامنيه انه يزعزع الامن
في المنطقه ويثير التوترات غير الضروريه
اننا ندين بشده هذه الاعمال وندعو كوريا
الشماليه الى وقفه تلك الاعمال غير
القانونيه المزعزعه للاستقرار اما رئيس
كوريا الجنوبيه فدعا الى فرض عقوبات على
كوريا الشماليه واعلن عن تعزيز وضع الدفاع
المشترك مع الولايات المتحده معلقا ان
بلاده تنشق مع المجتمع الدولي لما وصفه
بكبح جماح
السابقه
العديد من قرارات مجلس الامن وتهديدا
كبيرا للسلام والاستقرار لشبه جزيره
الكوريه ومنطقه اسيا والعالم اجمع
اليابان ان عمليه الاطلاق الصاروخيه غير
مقبوله اطلاقا من احتمال اطلاق كوريا
الشماليه مزيدا من الصواريخ
يشعروا الى انه وفي الاشهر الاخيره كشفت
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان من تعاونهم الامن ومن مناوراتهم
العسكريه المشتركه في مواجهه تحديدات
كوريا الشماليه المتزايد
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
هكذا بيان صادر في ختام زياره ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الى كوريا
الجنوبيه على التوافق لدافع العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه لافاق جديده وتوسيع نطاق
التعاون واقامه شركاه جديده بدوره اكد ولي
العهد السعودي تعزيز فرص التكامل
للاستثماري مع كوريا الجنوبيه في كل
المجلات على العمل مع كوريا الجنوبيه
لانجاح المشاريع الضخمه في المملكه كما
اكد الامير محمد بن سلمان على اهميه
التعاون مع كوريا الجنوبيه في مجالي
الطاقه الاصطناعي
من بانكوك ينضم الينا مفاجاه العربيه محمد
الطميح محمد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض ملخص اليوم الاول
الذي رصدته في هذه القمه قمه ابيك الملفات
السياسيه ايضا التي ضغط عليها بشكل كبير
القمه ساحه امريكيه جديده لممارسه المزيد
من الضغوط على موسكو فيما يتعلق في الحرف
الاوكراني خصوصا بعد التقارب والتفاهمات
الامريكيه الصينيه الاخيره التي وقعت على
هامش قمه العشرين في بالي ولكن هذا الذي
لم يحدث سوف في ذلك التجربه صاروخيه
الفارسيه التي اجرتها كوريا الشماليه
مؤخرا والتي ادت الى سقوط صاروخ في المياه
الاقتصاديه لليابان هذا الحادث دعى الى
اجتماع طارق شارك كثير الولايات المتحده
همم كندا استراليا نيوزلندا اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه اتفق المشاركون في هذه
همم القمه المصغره الطارعه التي كانت في
مشاركه نائبه رئيس الامريكي كما لاهرس الى
الى جانب اخر عن القمه الاساسيه او جلده
القمه الاساسيه طبعا اتفق المشاركون في
هذه القمه المصغره على التنديد التجربه
النوويه يا شماليه وصفوها بالابتزاز وكان
هناك مواقف سياسيه لافته ربما ادت الى
اهتمام اكبر بالتجربه صاروخيه الباريستيه
اكثر حتى من الحرب في اوكرانيا ولكن ظلت
القمه مستمره في جوانب اخرى احيانا بعدم
مشاركه القاده الذين كانوا يشاركون في هذا
الاجتماع
كان هناك تفاهمات فيما يتعلق مثلا بالطاقه
المستدامه تجار البينيه والاستثمار الحر
فيما يتعلق بدول المجموعه التي تؤثر ثقل
سياسي يربط ما بين اقتصادات الشرق والغرب
طبعا نشير وكما هو معروف هذه القمه وجهت
اا دعوه خاصه لولي العهد السعودي رئيس
مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن سلمان
للمشاركه في هذه القمه بالاضافه الى
الرئيس الفرنسيه
وكانت هذه مشاركه ايضا همم لافته الامير
محمد بن سلمان كاول همم زعيم عربي شرق
اوسطي يشارك في هذه القمه عدد من ثنائيه
ايضا التي عقدها على هامش هذه الزياره
التي يقوم بها الى همم تايلاند تفاهمات
اتفاقيات ما دعمها محمد
طبعا دعوه الامير محمد همم
ولي عهد لمملكه العربيه السعوديه رئيس
المجلس الوزراء لم تكن مجامله برتقاليه من
الدوله الوسطيفه واقصد هنا تايلاند
المملكه لها دور مؤثر ظهر جليا في الفتره
الاخيره مع ازمه الطاقه همم ايضا دورها
اكبر دوله مصدره للنفط في اوبك كلاس
استقرار اسواق الطاقه دورها في مجموعه 20
اسرع دوله في هذه المجموعه وايضا زياره
الامير محمد تاسس لعلاقات جديده ليس فقط
مع تايلند الدوله المستضيفه وانما ايضا مع
الدول اسيويه كبيره كان هناك لقاء ثنائيه
في بالي اللقاء استمرت هنا في همم بانكوك
بالاضافه الى لقاءات الدوليه التي جمعته
مع الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون التقى
عددا من القاده ااه الاسيويين مجددا يلتقى
همم رئيس اندونيسيا التقى سلطان بروناي
التقى الرئيس الفلبيني ورئيس وزراء همم
سنغافوره في هذه اللقاءات الثنائيه التي
جمعته مع القاده على هامش قمه ايبك نشير
هنا بان هذه اللقاءات تعزز ايضا علاقات
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتؤسس لعلاقات
سعوديه اسيويه عاليه المستوى وليس فقط مع
الدوله المستضيفه كما شرشرنا همم تايلاند
ما الذي تبقى اذن محمد من جوله ولي العهد
السعودي بعد ان شارك في قمه ال 20 بعد
انذار كوريا الجنوبيه وصل كذلك الى تايلا
كما شرط هذه الجوله هي المحطه الثالثه
لولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
التي بدات في بالي وصولا الى صول والان في
بانكوك من المتوقع ان يعقد الاميره المزيد
من اللقاءات ثنائيه مع القائد المشاركين
وضيوف ابيك 20 ولكن من المعلومات المتوفره
حتى الان جدول سمو ولي العهد سيكون هناك
لقاء يجمعه مع رئيس الوزراء التايلندي هذا
المساء ومن المتوقع
يشمل الى جانب العلاقات الثنائيه وبحث
العلاقات الثنائيه التي تطورت كبيرا بعد
زياره رئيس الوزراء تايلاندي الى الرياض
بدعوه من الامير محمد في الخامس والعشرين
من يناير في بدايه هذا العام فنحن نتحدثون
عن تعزيز علاقات بل تاسيس علاقات جديده ما
بين تايلاند والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
هذا اللقاء الرسمي سيعقد مساء اليوم
وسيكون هناك ايضا توقيع اتفاقات وتفاهمات
مشتركه ما بين لدين استكمالا ل همم
المنتدى السعودي التايلندي لاستثمار الذي
عقد برئاسه الوزير الاستثمار همم معالي
خالد الفالح في مطلع هذا الشهر في العاصمه
التايلانديه همم بانكوك نتوقع كما ذكر بعض
المصادر وبعض المصادر التايلنديه كما ذكرت
تلك المصادر ان تكون الاستثمارات السعوديه
خلال الفتره القريبه المقبله في تايلاند
بما يتجاوز عشره مليارات دولار كما تقول
المصادر اتايلانديه وهناك المزيد على
الجدول سمو ولي العهد سنوه فيكم بالمزيد
من التفاصيل حول او فورا كوفرها لا كل
التوفيق محمد شكرا جزيلا لك من همم بانكوك
انضم علينا موفد العربيه محمد
[موسيقى]
كشفت هيئه وعمليات التجاره البحريه في
البريطانيه عن معلومات لديها تفيد بان
مسيره ايرانيه تحوم فوق سفينه خليج عمان
صباح اليوم على بعد حوالي 50 ميلا بحريا
جنوب غرب مصر الهيئه واضافت في ذات الصدد
ان السفينه وطاقمها بخير
سلطنه عمان الاسبوع الماضي نفيد باستخدام
طائره مسيره ايرانيه الصنع وفق قياده
المركزيه الامريكيه
يتوجه رئيس الاركان الاسرائيليه عفيف
كوخافي الى الولايات المتحده غدا في زياره
يبحثوا خلال امام مسؤولين امريكيين
التحديات الامنيه بالمنطقه وفي مقدمتها
ايران اوضح الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الزياره
لا تستغرق خمسه ايام يجتمع خلالها كخافي
مع مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيكسوليفان كما يلتقي ايضا مع رئيس
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه وليمبرنس
رئيس الاركان المشتركه
من المسؤولين بالجيش الامريكي
من القاهره ينضم الينا رئيس مجلس اداره
صحيفه مصر اليوم الدكتور عبد المنعم سعيد
دكتور عبد المنعم مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض هذه الزياره برايك هل
تاتي في اطار مشاورات ثنائيه اسرائيليه
امريكيه كما المعتاد ام لا هناك بعد اخر
لهذه الزياره ويتعلق في الاساس بالملف
النووي الايراني الذي يبدو انه قد دخل الى
نفق المظلم كما يعلق بعض المراقبين
يعني هو طبعا معروف اني العلاقات
الاسرائيليه الامريكيه في المجال الاذاعي
والامن خاصه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
النصيحه
وتتكرر على جميع المستويات لكن عندما
يسافر رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي فعلا لم
تكن هذه الزياره مقرره
وانما من الواضح انه هناك شبكه الان
للتشاور من اجل كيفيه التعامل مع الموقف
ما بعد وصول بحساسه الامريكيه الايرانيه
في اطار الاتفاق النووي المعروف الموقع في
عام 2015
السيده التي
اه اه يعني طيب
في هذه النقطه الدكتور عبد المنعم يعني
كيف يمكن وكيف يمكن ايضا دكتور عبد المنعم
اذا سمحت يعني ان هناك عمليه في مصر
من خلال المصادر الايرانيه هل تسمعني
خاصه
امينه في معلومتها بالنسبه لوكاله الطاقه
النوويه الدوليه فيما يتعلق بالموضوع
السياحه الدكتور هل تسمعني اولا
اسمع جيدا طيب كنت تتحدث قبل قليل عن
الاحتجاجات في ايران عن الوضع الداخلي في
ايران وهنا اسال كيف يمكن لاسرائيل ااا ان
تستغلها هذا الموقف ال ال ال ال الموقف
الصعب بالنسبه لايران داخليا هذا الموقف
همم الشارع ايضا المحتاج
الاتفاقناوي كما ذكرت يعني وصل الى طريق
مسدود هنا هل يمكن لاسرائيل ان تستغل هذا
الموقف ان تحاول بحث عسكره هذا الموقف مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قبل اتخاذ اي
خطوه خصوصا مع قدوم
نتنياه الى السلطه في اسرائيل
يعني هو في شواهد كثيره على اختراقات سواء
امريكيه او اسرائيليه الى الداخليه
مختلفه بعضها ادى الى اغتيال بعض العلماء
بعضها الاخر الى احباط بعض الامور المؤديه
الى الجانب النووي او العسكري الايراني
لكن انا اعتقد هذه المساله العلاقه
الاساسيه تكون بين المخابرات الاسرائيليه
والمخابرات الامريكيه
الرئيس الامريكي
القوات المسلحه الاسرائيليه
صحيح انه هو سوف يلتقي
بالبرز اللي هو رئيس المخابرات وغيره انما
ذلك لكي يتم ذلك
الامور يجري مقارنه تصورات كل طرف او ما
لديه من جديد حول الحاله اليونانيه لكن
انا اعتقد ان الموضوع
استراتيجيه عامه تتعلق بالاتفاق النووي
الذي يعني تكون الخطوه القادمه خاصه انه
اولا حدث التوسل الى طريق مسدود ثانيا ان
اسرائيل ان ايران تقوم بعمليات غش تتعلق
يعني ما كان واجبا عليها في ظل الاتفاق
بالنسبه لوكاله الطاقه النوويه الدوليه
وبالتالي الدكتور عبد المنعم
اليوم وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي همم كانت
ادلب بعض التصريحات فيما يتعلق طبعا
بالموقف همم مع ايران وفي احدى التصريحات
قال همم يجب مواجهه نفوذ الايراني في
المنطقه وسنواصل التصدي لاي محاوله لاقامه
قواعد للارهاب على حدودنا هذه التصريحات
هل يمكن ان نربط بينها وبين اللقاء الذي
سيعقده رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي يوم غدا
مع
القيادات الاركان في المتحده الامريكيه
الاجتماعات ايضا كذلك مع جيك سوليفان
وليامبرس
هي مرتب
طه لكن طبعا هناك جانب عمليات في هذا
الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه لدى الطرفين الامريكي
والاسرائيلي وهناك جانب عملياته يتم
بالنسبه لمقاومه النفوذ الايراني على سبيل
المثال بالذات في سوريا هناك عمليات تحدث
وبعضها قوي وموجه الى عناصر ذات علاقه
بحزب الله في لبنان او لا علاقه بالحرس
الايراني مباشره هناك عمليات السابق في
العراق
متابعه دقيقه لان نفوز الايراني خاصه في
الجانب العسكري له يعني وسيله تحاول ايران
ان تستخدمها ايضا لتهديد الجانب الامريكي
وحلفاء
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من القاهره رئيس مجلس
اداره صحيفه مصر اليوم الدكتور عبد المنعم
سعيد
الرابعه مستمره او تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
ايضا
وزاره الصناعه السعوديه تعلن ارتفاع عدد
رخص استكشاف المعادن الى 55 رخصه
حياكم الله من جديد اعلانات وزاره التعليم
السعوديه عن بدء التقديمي على مسار التميز
للابتعاد في نسخته الثالثه على منصه سفير
اوضحت الوزاره ان التقديم سيكون متاحا حتى
الخامس من مايو من العام المقبل 2023 على
ان تعلن النتائج بعد المفاضله ابتداء من
شهر يونيو 2023 واكدت الوزاره ان التخصصات
التي يتضمنها مسار التميز تحقق متطلبات
التنميه الشامله وفق رؤيه 2030 حيث تدعم
التخصصات الجديده والقطاعات الواعده وتسهم
كذلك في تحقيق التنفسيه العالميه
الينا في الاستديو الدكتوره امل شقير وكيل
وزاره التعليم للابتعاد دكتور اهلا وسهلا
فيك معنا في نشرته خلينا اولا انا اعلم
بان هذا المسار هو في نسخته الثالثه وفي
السنه ايضا الثالث لكن نريد التذكير ايضا
به وان نعرف ما هو مسار التميز ما الذي
يختلف به عن غيره من مسارات
التميز هو احد مسارات اللي انطلقت ضمن
برنامج خادم الحرمين الشريفين الابتعاد تم
اطلاقه في عام 2020
هذه هي النسخه الثالثه
مسار التميز طبعا سمي بمساره التميز بحكم
انه الجميع الجامعات الموجوده في جامعات
متميزه في التخصصات التي تقدم فيها
اعتمد على اختيار الجامعات ذات
التقييم الالي في التصنيفات العالميه مثل
التايمز والكيو اس ول يو اس والشنغ هاي
همم حددت التخصصات انا على تميز هذه
الجامعات حسب هذا راكينج العالمي
همم
في الخبر ايضا
يذكر انه اعلان النتائج للمتقدمين على هذا
المسار ستتم بعد الماضله واسال هنا عن
المعايير اللي تتخذونها في المفاضله بين
المتقدمين عارف انه 1000 تقريبا
زي ما ذكر في الخبر ابتدات يوم امس 17 همم
نوفمبر وتستمر ان شاء الله الى شهر مايو
في شهر خمسه وتتم المفاضله بعد ذلك بعد
اقفال باب التقديم على المسار همم
ان شاء الله طبعا هي تستهدف العامل
الاكاديمي 23 24 يعني بذلك جميع همم
الفصول الدراسيه التي تبدا بشهر ثمانيه 23
حتى شهر سبعه في 27 همم بما انه هذا همم
مسار تخصص واتميز بانه جميع الاشتراطات
يعني مفتوحه لا يوجد عمر معين لا يوجد
تخصص او امتداد تخصص محدد فكانت عندنا
معايير محدده للاختيار بين المتقدمين
المعيار الاول وهو همم الرانكينج التي
تحصل عليه الجامعه فلنقل ان متقدمين تحت
قدموا على جمعتين مختلفين مختلفتين يفضل
همم اخر همم قبول في الجامع يكون افضل
المعيار الثاني هي الدرجه او
التقدير الذي حصل عليه الطالب في الدرجه
العلميه السابقه لذلك في المكان الرجل
معدل المرتفع اذا يكون له الافضل المعيار
الثالث
وانا مثلا ادرس محاسبه وفي شخص اخر يدرس
مثلا يقول تخصص هندسه او الشخص اللي في
المحاسبه المعدله مرتفع اعلى من اللي في
الهندسه بالتالي هو هذا الشخص يكون همم
اكثر فعلا
المؤهل تقدير الذي حصل عليها الطالب هو
الذي تعاير عليها المفاصل بغض النظر على
التخصصات همم بالنسبه للمعيار الثالث
المعيار الثالث يتحدث عن همم ان يكون
المتقدم مقدم على درجه طبعا في شيء مميز
كذلك في هذه المسار ان الطالب ممكن يتعث
على نفس درجه سبق له الحصول عليها لنقول
انا حصلت على درجه الماجستير او درجه
الدكتوراه وقدمت على نفس الدرجات فاذا كان
في طالب لم يحصل عليها وطالب حصل عليها
تكون الاولويه للطالب الذي لم يحصل عليه
الصلاه والسلام
في المسارات همم تتضمن مسار يتضمن مسار
التميز همم كما ذكر في ال- همم الخبر هي
مسارات تحقق متطلبات التنميه الشامله وفق
رؤيه المملكه 20 30 هل يعني هنا في التغير
في التخصصات التي تستهدفوها في في النسخه
الثالثه
اطلق اطلق لي استهدف تخصصات تتوافق مع
رؤيه المملكه واحداثها الاصطدام على سبيل
المثال العلوم الامنيه السياحه الفندقه
علوم البحار همم هذه تخصصات كلها واعده
وتستهدفها المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
رؤيتها وفي تحقيق في تحقيق التنميه
الشامله للمجتمع فبذلك تخصص السههدفت
لتختلف او اا طبعا نفسك تخصصات السابقه
موجوده ولكن زادت عليها تخصصات تتطلع
المملكه في توسيعها في دائره الاكاديميه
المعايير احنا عرفناها
للطلاب الامتحان بتاعتهم بس بالنسبه
لمعايير اختيار الجامعات التخصصات ايضا في
الجامعات كيف تتمها العمليه دكتوره
في البدايه كما ذكرت نعتمد على اربع
معايير عالميه هي معيار تايمز والكيو اس
والي يو اس هاي همم عندنا قائمتين من
الجامعات طبعا هذا الجامعات تقريبا 70
الجامعه الهمم المجموعه الاولى من
الجامعات هي جامعه هي جامعه هي قائمه عامه
القائمه هذه تستهدف 51 جامعه ال تقييم
حقها هو الاعلى هو الاعلى 51 جامعه بشكل
عام في جميع التخصصات اا طبعا عدد
التخصصات الموجوده في هذا المسار هي 21
تخصص فكلما وجد في هذه الجامعات ال 51 همم
من تخصصات تتوافق مع ال 21 جامعه هي
مقبوله بالنسبه للجامعات الخاصه تستهدف
حسب التخصص فلذكر على سبيل المثال في علوم
البحار تستهدف الجامعات ذات التقييم
الاعلى العالميه في علوم البحار قد تختلف
تقريبا عن الجامعات الموجوده في القائمه
الاولى فاولا واخيرا التقييم هو على حسب
تقييم الجامعه
في هذا المسار وغيرهم المسارات همم برنامج
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الابتعاد ضمه في
الاستديو الدكتوره امل شكيل وزاره التعليم
الدكتور شكرا يعني
كشفت وزاره صناعه والثروه المعدنيه
السعوديه ان عدد تراخيص الاستكشاف السريعه
في قطاع التعدين قد بلغ 550 رخصه موزعه
على 11 منطقه اداريه حول السعوديه اوضحت
الوزاره ان الشركات الوطنيه الحاصله على
الرخص السحودات على نسبه الاكبر بواقع
97% فيما بلغت نسبه الرخص الممنوحه الى
الشركات المشتركه بين الاستثمار الاجنبي
والمحلي ثلاثه في المئه
يا سعد هو ملتقى الاستثمار بمنطقه القصيم
في منطقه القصيم 150 فرصه استثماريه
بالمنطقه متاحه للاستثمار لدى مختلف
الجهات الحكوميه والتي تترجم خارطه نمو
الاقتصادي لمستقبل المنطقه تنمويه
واقتصاديا عبر جلسات بين المستثمرين وعدد
من الجهاد الحكوميه
ممكناته ومحافظات نمو الاستثمار واستدامه
الاعمال واقعوا الاستثمار بالقصير من وجهه
نظر المستمر كانت هذه العناوين الابرز
للجلسات الرئيسيه لملتقى الاستثمار
بالقصيم
بمشاركه عدد من الجهات الحكوميه وصانعي
القرار من ثمانيه قطاعات حيويه وشركات
المحليه واجنبيه بمركز الملك خالد
الحضاريده
متنوعه تجاوزت 100 فرصه وهي مختلفه ما بين
فنادق وما بين مستشفيات ما بين مدن طبيه
متكامله وعندنا مشاريع ايضا حكوميه اكثر
من تسعه فرس حكوميه موجوده في امانه
القصيم عندنا مناطق سياحيه كبيره جدا في
جبل طميه مثل العسل ثمانيه قطاعات حيويه
تعرضوا 250 فرصه استثماريه بملتقى
الاستثمار بالقصيم
تنوعت بين الصناعات سياحه والخدمات
اللوجستيه والتجاره والاعمال
صوت القطاع الخاص في رسم الفرصه المناسبه
والتصميمها امر مهم جدا وذلك احنا مهم
اننا نجدد هذه المتقيات مع شركائنا من
القطاع الخاص ونستمع لرايهم حول هذه الفرص
اللي نطرحها ونتاكد دائما اننا نواكب
التغيرات بيئه الاعمال ونطرح الفرص
الجاذبه لكافه المستثمرين والمختلفاتهم
يهجف الملتقى الى ابراز امكانات منطقه
القصيم وتوفير الفرس والمشاريع الاكثر نمو
واستداما وخلق المبادرات لتحسين جوده
البيئه الاستثماريه بالمنطقه من بريده
سلطان السلامي العربيه
اختتمت السعوديه فاعليه بلاكهاد ثم موسم
الرياض الحالي بحضور فاقه 30,000 زائر تحت
تنظيم هيئه الترفيه والاتحاد الدولي للامن
السيبراني مشاهده الفاعليه الاكبر عالميا
في مجال الامن السيبراني اكثر من 200 جلسه
حواريه وورشه عمل بالاضافه الى الانشطه
التفاعليه ومعرض شارك به نحو 300 شركه
معظمها عالميه المستوى
في السعوديه اعلنت مطاراته جده عن خطتها
التشغيليه لاستقبال الراغبين في حضور
مباريات بطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم 2022
والمقرر اقامتها في قطر وتضمنت خطه مطارات
جده اجراءات تسهيليه عده منها تخصيص صالات
لمشجع كاس العالم وتوفير حافله نقل
وفريق متخصص ايضا للاجابه عن الاستفسارات
كافه
من صلاته مطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده التي
تخصصت لنقل جماهير كاس العالم الى قطر
انضم الينا مراسل العربيه هاني الصبيان
هاني مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشرته
الرابع من الرياض الحمدلله على السلامه
عودتك من اوكرانيا اولا همم هاني هذا لديك
من معلومات ارقام ايضا همم حصلت عليها من
وصولك الى هذه الصاله المخصصه طبعا لنقل
الجماهير اا كاس العالم الى قطر ابرز
الاستعدادات التي رصدتها ايضا
نعم نايف اجواء مختلفه اذا هنا في مطار
الملك عبد العزيز في جده خاصه بعد وضع خطه
تشغيليه محدده واضحه لمن اجل تامين وتسهيل
اجراءات المسافرين الذين سوف
يتوجهون الى وجهتهم الاخيره من اجل حضور
كاس العالم هذه الخطه كانت من خلال توفير
اكثر من 350 من الصلاه لنهائي اجراءاتهم
اضافه الى ان هناك ايضا ثمانينه منصه
للانهاء الاجراءات الذاتيه ايضا عبر شركه
مطارات جده وكذلك او بالاصح شركه مطره جده
عبر مطار الملك عبد العزيز وفرت اماكن همم
خاصه وصالتين سواء اصاله رقم واحد والتي
نتواجد فيها الان والتي نشاهدها من خلال
همم استقبال المغادرين للرحلات المجدوله
وكذلك هناك صاله اخرى وهي صاله الحجاج
التي ايضا سوف تخصص لي ايضا الرحلات
التردديه او كذلك بعض الرحلات الترانزيت
طبعا من اجل سلامه ووصول هؤلاء المغادرين
او كذلك القادمين من خارج السعوديه والذي
يتوقع ان يصل عددهم اكثر من 200,000 مسافر
سوف يحضرون نهائي الى نهائيات همم او كاس
العالم في قطر سوف يكون عددهم اكثر من
200,000 تم توفير استراحات وغرف وكذلك
هناك حافلات سوف تنقلهم من مكان في فتره
الراحه اثناء وصولهم الى الغرف الاستراحات
التي تخصصات التي يتجاوز مساحتها اكثر من
12,000 متر مربع يعني نتحدث ان خلال
الساعه الواحده سوف تخصص لاكثر من سته
الاف
ايضا الفعاليات التي من الممكن او هي
تتواجد الفعل هي هنا هناك ايضا مركز
للاستعلامات وكذلك ارشادات وضعت بشكل تقني
حتى يسهل على عمليه المسافرين الذين سوف
يغادرون من مطار الملك عبد العزيز او كذلك
القادمين الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز كم من
دول اوروبيه وكذلك امريكا تسهيل اجراءاتهم
حتى وصولهم الى وجهتهم النهائيه الامر هنا
مختلف قد يكون نايف وكذلك مشاهدي قناه
العربيه اذا تحدثنا ان هناك او الفتره
الماضيه خلال الشهر الماضي حضر اكثر من
30,000 من الذين او من اوروبا من امريكا
واوروبا والذين سوف يرغبون بالتوجه الى
نهائيات كاس العالم ولكن رغبه بالوصول الى
السعوديه وكذلك ايضا همم اخذ جوله سياحيه
يتعرف بشكل اكثر على السعوديه خاصه ان
هناك
ممتاز
ومقر من وزاره السياحه وضع في مطار الملك
عبد العزيز من اجل ارشادهم وكذلك توجيههم
الى الاماكن السياحيه المعروفه في
السعوديه خاصه في ظل هذه الاوقات الجميله
التي تشهدها السعوديه في فترات ما اكتوبر
وكذلك نوفمبر حتى مارش القادم وكذلك يتوقع
ان يزداد هذا العدد الى اكثر من ثلاثه
اضعاف عند انتهاء نهائيات كاس العالم
بعودته من السعوديه وكذلك تجول فيها
مناطقم السياحيه خاصه ان هناك من من
يحضرون الى كاس العالم هم قادمين من
امريكا الجنوبيه وكذلك امريكا والدول
البعيده التي من الصعب عليهم العوده مره
اخرى هذه فرصه لهم جيده لاتفرج على
السعوديه خاصه من خلال الاعلانات التي
كانت تقدمها وزاره السياحه في الفتره
الماضي
المعلومات التفصيليه هذه الارقام ايضا
التي نقل لانها من صلاه مطار الملك عبد
العزيز بجده
مراسل العربيه عن الصيام شكرا جزيلا لك
رابع مستمره وفيها ايضا
امانه منطقه حائل تطلق مشروعا لاضاءه
الواجهه الجبليه عن طريق اكثر من الفا 300
وحده
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد اوضح مازن الجاري
الرئيس التنفيذي لموسم حائل 2022 ان
النسخه الثانيه من الموسم التي انطلقت من
17 والتي تستمر حتى ثالث والعشرين من
ديسمبر المقبل تتضمن انشطه متنوعه اهمها
كاس موسم حائل للصقور وسباق الهجن
بالاضافه لقريه كاس العالم المجهزه
لمشاهده مباريات مونديال قطر 2022
ابتداء من اليوم كان كاس موسم حائل للصقور
الى ثلاثه ايام 17 18 19 من نوفمبر بجوائز
ماليه تصل الى سته
وبعد كده عندنا فاعليه كاس موسم حائل
للسباق الهجن باذن الله راح تكون في
العاشر
بالاضافه الى فعاليه رياضيه اخرى وهي كاس
موسم هائل لرميه السهام همم بالاضافه الى
عندنا فعاليات ترفيهيه رياضيه تستهدف جميع
افراد العائله او من ابرز الفعاليات
الترفيهيه اللي راح تكون في منطقه المغوه
هي قريه كاس العالم من خلالها جميع الحضور
يقدروا يشاهدوا مباريات كاس العالم
اطلقت امنت منطقه حائل للاعمال الفنيه
لمشروع اضاءه واجهه الجبليه عبر وحدات
اضاءه تفاعليه تستعرض العديد من
السنوريوهات من خلال اكثر من 1300 وحده
اضاءه مربوطه بشبكه
البيانات عاليه السرعه وتمتد الواجهه
الجبليه في حائل لاكثر من خمسه الاف متر
طولي بمشهد بانورامي يقع في اعلى
المستويات الارضيه ارتفاعا
في المشروع الواجهه الجبليه بمنطقه حائل
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سالم الراجح
سالم مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض ما شاء الله عليك سالم
شتي والاجواء حلوه في حائل اليوم ومشروع
اضاءه جبليه كلمنا عننا اكثر بعد ما
تكلمنا طبعا
اهلا نايف مساء الخير لكم مشاهدينا الكرام
نعم الاجواء في حال صلاح من اسبوع تقريبا
هي اجواء ماطره طالما حديث عن اجفا قمم
اجوا من اسبوع تقريبا تتغطى بالغيوم و
الضباب ويبقى الحديث مستمر عن جبال اجا
تحديدا عن مشروع الواجهه الجبليه وكما
اسماته امانه منطقه حائل نور على جاء هذا
المشروع الذي بدا العمل الميداني فيه
تقريبا اعمال الانشائيه والفنيه منذ شهر
تقريبا كما سنشاهد بعد قليل في الصور
الحديث اكثر ينضم معنا المهندس سعود
العالي المشرف العام على الاعلام والتواصل
المؤسسه في امانه منطقه حائر مهند سعود
والبدايه نريد ان تعطينا نبذه اكثر عن هذا
المشروع همم نعم حياك الله وتحيه طيبه لك
ولي في طريقه عمل
المشاهد الكريم همم سالم همم كما تفضلت
همم جبل جاء باعتباره المعلم الوقور في
مدينه حائل همم لذ نشاهد هذا الاشم في
الفتره النهاريه وهو يظهر بكامل همم
جمالياته وتضاريسه وحسنه ورسمه همم ولكننا
نعمل هذا اليوم بامانه منطقه حائل في منح
هذا الجبل قيمته الجماليه مساء همم من همم
خلال همم
طبعا يعني همم كما تعلم نزيل او يعني نزيح
هذه الكتله الظلاميه همم عن الجبل بوحداتي
اضاءه همم تفاعليه
وملونه ويعني موفره للطاقه لكن المشروع
راح يكون المشروع اضاءه تقليديه يعني مثل
ما اشوف كثير مواقع حيويه ويكون فيها نوع
من هذه الاضاءه ما هو الجديد في هذا
المشروع يعني همم لا شك سالم ان الاضاءه
التقليديه تعتبر عنصر جميل خلال الفتره
المسائيه ولكن ما استجد لدينا في هذا
المشروع
ان الاضاءه تعتبر
عبر احدث يعني التقنيات الحديثه
لمجال يعني اللايتنج اضاءات يعني ذكيه
ربطت في شبكه
بيانات لخلق سيناريوهات متعدده اضاءات
ملونه اضاءات
تفاعليه اا اضاءات همم يعني يقول فيها هذا
الجبل لن ابقى صامتا خلال الفتره المسائيه
بعد هذا اليوم
تشغيل هذا المشروع راح يكون على مدار
العام امرتبط في مناسبات معينه يعني همم
لا شك انه سيكون على مدار العام همم اضافه
الى انه يوجد لدينا رزنامه من المناسبات
الوطنيه همم من الايام او المناسبات يعني
العالميه التي همم سنتفاعل معها طيله هذا
العام همم
بسيناريوهات تكون يعني همم بصراحه المحدده
لهذه المناسبات
ان شاء الله جبل اجازه سيرا النور خلال
ثمان اشهر من الان شكرا جزيلا المهندس
سعود حياك الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا جزيلا
نعم كنا معكم من الاعمال الفنيه
والميدانيه لمشروع الاناره اناره الواجهه
الجبليه في منطقه حائل نور على جبل شكرا
جزيلا همم لضيفك الكريم انضم الينا من حق
المراسل العربيه او مفرد العربيه
تمتاز محافظه الريت في منطقه جازان جنوب
غرب السعوديه بالتشكيلات الصخريه الملونه
والكهوف التي شكلت بيئه فنيه ورسوما
تاريخيه تعود لالاف الاعور نشاهد
[موسيقى]
والملونه والكهوف المحفوره من ابرز مميزات
محافظه الري جنوب السعوديه التي شكلت منها
بيئه قابله لفن النقش والتحنيط ورسم
الاثار التي يصل عمرها وتاريخها لاكثر من
ثمانيه الاف عام موضوع اختيار البيئه
الجيولوجيا الكوفه الموجوده الالوان
الصخور اللي موجوده
همم يلون فيها النقش او النحت او الرسم او
الرسم المنقوط مليانه في البيئه وهي اللي
وصلت عمرها
7000 الى 8000 عام احنا لو تكلمنا عن وجود
الانسان البشري بدايه من هنا وجود الرجل
الاول في الكاف وهو موجود في البيئه
لوحاتهم فنيه تتكون على جبال الريت من
خلال خلط الالوان الناتجه عن طحن الصخور
طبيعيا والتي قام بصنعها السكان القدامى
لهذه المناطق حيث وجدت اثار تعود للعصور
الحجريه كثير من انواع النبات الموجود
يخلط مع بعض ويطبق فيه الجلد
وتثبت هذه المواد في الكهف طبعا الاختيار
الكهف همم الشمس ما تجيء عليه الامطار ما
تجيء عليه الهواء عليه اذا يثبت الى اعلى
وحده العامل الاساسي اللي موجود انه صخور
والكهوف والالوان المحيطه بالمكان ولا
يثبت لهذا العمر
الاف سنه الا هذه المواد الطبيعيه
تمتد النقوش الحجريه في جبال الريس لاكثر
من 15 مترا والتي تعكس صوره عن تاريخ قديم
كان وما زال مرجعيه ثقافيه وفنيه كبرى من
جبال الريس اسامه القاسم العربيه
توقع المركز الوطني للارصاد انخفاض درجات
الحراره اليوم على الاجزاء الشماليه من
المنطقه الشرقيه والوسطى مع استمرار هطول
الامطار الرعديه المسحوبه برياح نشطه
ومثيره للالتربه والغبار وزخاتم من البرد
على اجزاء من المناطق الحدود الشماليه
وحائل والقصيم هذا وتوقعت الارصاد ان تكون
السماء غائمه جزئيا تتخللها سحب الرعديه
ممطره على اجزاء من مناطق الباحه وعسير
وجزاء مع تكون الضباب خلال الليل وساعه
صباح الباكر على اجزاء من المناطق القسيمه
حائل والشرقيه وجزان وعسير والباحه
ومرتفعات مكه
اه مع اجواء الشتاء الممطره نختم الرابعه
بابرز عناوين
ولي العهد السعودي يلتقي عددا من القاده
المشاركين في قمه افيك ويبحث معهم الملفات
المشتركه
الامير محمد بن سلمان يؤكد على اهميه
التعاون مع كوريا الجنوبيه وتعزيز فرص
التكامل الاستثماري
رئيس الاركان الاسرائيليه يبحث غدا في
واشنطن التحديات الامنيه في المنطقه وفي
مقدمتها تهديدات ايران
وزاره التعليم السعوديه تعلن بدء التقديمي
على نسخه الثالثه من مسار التميز للابتعاد
وزاره الصناعه السعوديه تعلن ارتفاع عدد
رخص استكشاف المعادن الى 55 رخصه
شكرا لكم
يوم غدا في رعايه
[تصفيق]